hello again since we last spoke I've
been busy playing with my new player
banging this board I played a couple of
tournaments in in Holland and I can say
and in Germany in baden-baden both of
those tournament I was lucky enough to
win lucky enough but who who doesn't
like a bit of false modesty here and
there but anyway in I could say I
started out pretty badly but as I guess
some of you may know I had a really good
winning streak at the end of the
tournament I mean at the middle of the
tournament and then it kind of slowed
down at the end but nevertheless I I
have very pleasant memories from from
that tournament this year and it's it
was it was definitely something to build
on for the next of the year for the rest
of the year after that I went home for
for a week I managed to recharge the
batteries quite quite well and as I
started the tournament in baden-baden I
felt I felt refreshed and I thought
there was every chance of doing well
then unfortunately I lost in the third
round in in a very long and exciting if
not very good game and I had to I had to
play catch-up again
but I managed to share first place and
when when the tiebreak which was a
memorable memorable moment since I've
gotten back home I've been playing a bit
of football with my team
I really like it when I'm able to train
regularly with with them to get get into
to a decent shape so now for a few weeks
I've been able to - yeah - play some
football practice a bit of chest and -
in general feel good well what position
do you play in football in my last game
I am I changed the position from from
left back to the striker and I I think
that's going to be my natural position
from from now on sorry is strong soccer
player - I'm not very strong soccer
player but I'm I'm I can shoot and
what's next on the game plan for next
time I will have a training session
before my next tournament in in
Azerbaijan in April so I'm looking
forward to that
I already have a lot of ideas for what
we're gonna do to prepare for that
tournament so as good as it is to be
home I'm already looking forward to the
training and and
hope to see you again soon and we'll be
right back with a smile